Has the Marvel Cinematic Universe finally
found its Adam Warlock?
Entertainment news site We Got This Covered
claims they have an anonymous source with
insider knowledge, and that source says Marvel
Studios executives are eyeing Stranger Things
breakout star Dacre Montgomery to portray
Adam Warlock in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol.
3.
This undisclosed source also says Montgomery
is actually one of many actors that the studio
has placed on its Warlock wishlist, so hardcore
fans of his shouldn't go screaming on social
media that he's a shoo-in for the part.
The insider also stated that casting for Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 3 hasn't even officially
begun as of mid-July 2019, though they did
share that Montgomery is likely to be "in
the running" once Marvel and writer-director
James Gunn finally get the gears on the long-awaited
threequel turning.
Third-party reports claim that casting for
the third Guardians movie will begin in November,
so it seems plausible that Marvel could start
making a list of contenders a few months in
advance.
It should be noted that Marvel hasn't actually
confirmed the presence of Adam Warlock in
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3, so we're not
entirely sure if the character will even be
a part of the story.
Talk amongst the Marvel community claims that
Adam, the artificially created being meant
to serve as the perfect human and the pinnacle
of evolution, will somehow cross paths with
the Guardians as they search for their lost
member Gamora after the past version of herself
vanished during the battle with Thanos in
Avengers: Endgame.
The reason for this theory is down to two
things: a mid-credits scene from Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 2, in which the Sovereign
High Priestess Ayesha reveals that she created
a powerful being to destroy the Guardians:
"I think I shall call him, 'Adam'."
And then there's Gunn's past mention that
Adam was meant to appear in Guardians Vol.
2, but would instead pop up in a later franchise
installment.
In 2017, Gunn discouraged fans from believing
that Adam would definitely be in Guardians
Vol. 3, though that clearly hasn't stopped
them from speculating about the exact opposite.
Adam Warlock's MCU debut feels inevitable,
and it's certainly a long time coming, given
that he was even in talks to appear in the
supersized superhero ensemble Avengers: Endgame.
Such an appearance would have been appropriate,
since Adam has had a complicated history with
Endgame's main antagonist Thanos, first partnering
with the Mad Titan to destroy his eventual
evil alter ego Magus, then serving as his
biggest rival.
Endgame screenwriters Christopher Markus and
Stephen McFeely ultimately felt like it would
be too much of a, quote, "backbend" to introduce
Adam in the film, so that seedling of a thought
never sprouted.
Montgomery would be a nice fit for Adam Warlock,
as the 24-year-old Aussie actor has had experience
in the superhero arena before, previously
playing the Red Ranger in 2017's Power Rangers
reboot.
He may face fierce competition in the fight
to portray Adam Warlock - if he's truly in
consideration for it, of course.
Zac Efron, who recently stunned in Netflix's
Extremely Wicked, Shockingly Evil and Vile,
has also been rumored to be up for the role
in Guardians Vol. 3.
Even if Montgomery does lose out on the gig,
the Stranger Things star could very well be
a part of the superhero franchise in a totally
different capacity.
Many fans are hoping that once Marvel Studios
reboots the X-Men franchise in the aftermath
of Disney's acquisition of 20th Century Fox,
Montgomery will become the new Wolverine - a
younger version of the character famously
played by fellow Aussie Hugh Jackman.
At this stage, it's all just speculation,
but one thing is clear: Dacre Montgomery is
having one hell of a summer.
"Perfect form."
"Well, your form is amazing."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.